horrible night in 1996 made a deal with
the Charlotte Hornets to get Kobe Bryant
in a Laker uniform Jerry huh I want to
know what you saw in those like it was
it two workouts you saw this teenage kid
Kobe Bryant and what knock your socks
off well excuse me
sorry totally understandable
you know it's wasn't like this was some
great discovery because people knew who
he was
at that time Oh
it wasn't in vogue to take 17 years old
kids and we were having a workout and
his agent aren't tell him and I have
been longtime friends and he said I'd
like he wants to come and work out with
some of these players that were going to
be higher taking in and draft everyone
thought and he goes there and I watched
this 17 years old and I said to myself
this is ridiculous
these kids know what kids doing involved
here and they were three four years in
college and I said this is a waste
because I hope we don't have to drive on
those guys when the process is a young
man sitting beside me here that also
figured into this plan and so again Kobe
Bryant through his agent they were
trying to direct him here to us and our
big prize the showcase of our franchise
was going to be Shaquille O'Neal if we
could convince him to come here at that
point in time you could not communicate
because of bigs in negotiation with the
players and walked out
so Kobe wanted to come back again and
work out for us and so Arne called me
and said he's in town here and he wants
to work out so I bought Michael Cooper
in and I think some of you people know
who Michael Cooper is like one of the
great defenders we've had in our way
and so we wanted him to play well Kobe
Bryant and see what it looked like well
after 10 minutes I said let's talk this
okay
he was embarrassing Michael and I told
Michael I said man he retired soon
enough
and that was a genesis of it spent
countless days trying to straight our
starting center plot a debauch to create
space too so hopefully we could attract
to kill and she killer not never met in
person and we developed a relationship
but with a clone which was very honest
and that's the only thing I believe in
when you're dealing fires you cannot
ever lie to it for never and finally one
day of late Jerry Buss who was he only
had two or three people working for us
at that point in time and I told you
kill and I really remember this I said
you should kill we just drafted a kid
who's the best player in the draft
that's what I know you got a lot of good
players down in Orlando but I said we
have better players here and we have one
it's going to be the best player in the
league one day pretty bold statement to
make but to me it was obvious
Charles watching you Duane watching you
get Reggie watching you feel watching
you it was easy to identify and so this
process live on and all of a sudden our
dream came true we got Shaquille O'Neal
we got Kobe Bryant
probably as hard for me because the
times I spent with him when it was 17
years old at my house constantly wanting
me to go to the gym watching him playing
the summer league and you know everyone
was excited to see a young kid like that
and he's having dinner at your table and
on nights yes and having dinner at my
house my son Ryan was his first best
friend in town who work for the Lakers
for number year drove him around and to
watch this relationship but he was
uniquely differ let me tell you why it
was different he always talked about
this mom the mentality he didn't have to
create that it was already there and to
watch him search out information to
watch him one time some way to get
better every year and I spent four years
of my life watching this and I made a
trade with the Miami Heat
I traded Eddie Jones who was an all-star
player the reason why Kobe Bryant needed
to start I was kind of vilified about it
the best thing that ever happened but I
think the thing that resonates with me
the most this is incredible career
this is a sad city right now one person
with one name Koli you don't have to
admit new class span and to see the
pictures for him but his daughter
sending it games hugging hugging them to
get a Christmas card from them every
year and to watch this incredible family
grow and prosper and now to see not one
the two the three families gone saddest
day of my wife lost a brother in Korea
and who the only thing that compares to
this to me
you don't want to ramble on very much
but I had a special relationship with
him no one knows the intimate call box I
had with him
no one knows even people who are close
to it they don't know the conversations
I had with him they don't know the
conversations I had with him in Memphis
when I was working in Memphis we still
communicated and I remember when he was
going to lead the Lakers and I've never
really mentioned this to anyone he was
don't come and sign with the Clippers
who I'm now involved with us a
consultant and I told him Toby
under no circumstances can you do this
and he was mad at everyone at the Laker
if the owner everyone else I said Co
week you can't go play with the Clippers
you can't play for that owner period we
had two conversations about and he
supposedly made a commitment to the
Clippers and after the last one we
talked last time but there's so many
things that we talked about as he was
just seeking information he and his
parents were with him for a while
and honestly I felt like these father
for two years
I don't know if I can get over this
everybody'll